imagine vampire academy sort of meets
the host but a good version of that yeah
and with some hunger games throwing a
little bit of hunger future utopia
yeah exactly
hey guys i'm ryan wright and i am jerry
welcome to reasons to see where we give
you reasons
to see and maybe not to see divergent
so let's hang out
so we saw divergent we did i saw two
trailers for this movie and both
trailers i was like this movie it looks
like a total piece of [ __ ] in
every possible way i saw one trailer for
this forgot what it was about and then
realized i didn't know a thing about it
until i got to the
i saw this movie just just this morning
literally just got back from it i
[ __ ] loved it
i figured you would i thought it was
awesome
it was really cool okay the story itself
is pretty neat they basically
it's a hundred years after the war not
sure what war was
but some kind of war some kind of war
you know how it goes i'm sure we'll find
out in part two
and or three yeah so basically
everyone's divided up into
you know five different factions yeah
yeah and uh you know she wants to be
part of the uh
what's that faction called dauntless
dauntless this is the warrior class
there's like the the really smart people
who are called aerial diet there's the
warrior class which is dauntless there
are like the really truthful honest
people who are called
something i've forgotten now um i don't
know the maccabees they're like the
farmer people
the group she comes from is called
abnecation
yeah abnegation and they're about
compassion and charity all the groups
are like very calm and peaceful and then
you got the cops who are like
whoa yeah they're basically the parkour
team
yeah that's what they are that's what i
was thinking too when i was watching it
i mean like
on the one hand it's cool i got a little
distracted because every time they show
up they're just jumping on your [ __ ]
and like i'm like is this
is somebody doorbelling you yeah that's
probably my landlord
literally just got uh my first threat to
get kicked out because i was being too
loud
yeah we had to stop filming because my
landlord was like you you got to keep it
down you got to keep it down then you
went to this whole thing because this is
my third noise complaint in one week
yeah
be careful i gotta be careful i got i
gotta whisper these reviews you
you do like your stuff loud i do like
being loud
it's a weird thing i really like being
loud like the um
cops was in diversion oh oh the
dauntless the dominus
the warrior class now i'm afraid to
express myself because i'm just like is
my landlord
listening to me with a directional mic
right now back to divergent like every
time the dauntless show up it's like
they're just showing off and like
jumping on stuff and i'm like this seems
kind of
you guys don't need to be doing this and
when they go to training
it's like this is the most serious place
in the goddamn planet yeah
it's like you might not make it out of
here a lot yeah you will probably
die if you don't comply and if you fail
you will just be a homeless
it's a cool story though um i like how
the war happened and now the world's
divided up into five sections
and only blacks and whites have survived
there's not anybody
else in this movie that's a different
ethnicity in between that's another cast
of children
yeah only black people and white people
made it white people and a couple of
black dudes and there you go
you know you hear that term young adult
novel thrown around all the time you
think of twilight yeah you think
you think of like shitty ass movies like
twilight even the host and like
you know just silly [ __ ] movies and
this movie had its moments of cheesiness
but overall i was able to take it pretty
serious throughout this movie is a lot
more hunger games than it is twilight
like oh definitely i can't avoid those
young adult novel movie
cliches of like oh here's the moment
where
they find a way to take his shirt off
there's this moment where the guy takes
his shirt off number four
or four is his name yeah he takes his
shirt off and then he has his
awesome tattoo on his back she's like a
powerful [ __ ] dude and then
he she touches his back and he goes ooh
stings
it's almost become trophy now where they
all all these movies have their own
terminology and i wish there was a way
to make that a little more smooth
because there's always that one moment
during the movie where they look
emphatically toward the camera and they
go no yeah i'm a divergent
yeah that was like that was great
cheesiest all right
awesome chill with chill with your
terminology i like
stories like this where it's like wow so
if you just gave them some freedom you
you would eliminate them huh and like
that's the whole point of being a
divergent is you can't be multiple
things you got to belong to one category
and i ain't cool with that [ __ ]
sorry now i just hear my landlord every
time i
apparently slightly erase my voice yeah
yeah no i mean it's
it's a cool version of the future you
know everyone's sci-fi story for sure it
sounds like the book was probably a lot
bigger than this actual film have you
ever read the book
it always is and and it's just because
sometimes it felt like well we didn't
really need that when he when [ __ ]
the friend betrays her and then kills
himself i'm like that's a little like
whoa
we kind of don't need that sinister but
it kind of happened out of nowhere
it's depressing but really unnecessary
for this film you could have chopped
that out i wish they could have given us
a better glimpse into their society
though because i'm like how did you guys
make it at least a hundred years without
this happening
already yeah i think exactly how did
nobody get upset or
[ __ ] with the system by now yeah how do
they get it so perfect how do people
just conform to all this but it still is
cool i guess it's definitely a cool idea
and i hope they can expand
and and maybe explain some of those
things in the subsequent films
and sheriff woody is awesome in this
film man elaine woodley
cheryl you know whatever i call her
sheriff woody she's awesome yes
she's hot want to do stuff sexually with
her she is awesome
and she's a good actress too i really
like i really liked her performance a
lot i was you know like
i was getting pumped up when i was
watching this movie
i was like i want to be in a [ __ ]
action movie right now that looks cool
with your [ __ ] assault rifle
little futuristic gun well the the cool
thing too especially with her
performance is
this movie does actually allow for some
real emotional moments
yeah which is like oh [ __ ] like you're
really you guys are dealing with the
aftermath of a decision you just made
like holy crap this is great and i
thought the most interesting part
i'd say like a good maybe third maybe
two thirds of this
was like just the training and the
training was
really interesting you know it starts
off with like that typical training like
here you're going to be a warrior badass
but especially when it got into like
dealing with the dream sequences
i thought that was really [ __ ] neat
how to face your fear and what i didn't
really like was that they could see
inside their mind for some reason i was
like that's
i can't buy that i don't know why i
guess i guess you're right it's like you
live a hundred years in the future but
you don't really look like you have that
nice of it like that technological of a
society
yeah yeah yeah but as far as sheriff
woody goes she is [ __ ] awesome dude
you know
they call this the follow up to the
hunger games i thought like yeah i mean
if you're gonna follow it up with a cool
female lead i think she's a great female
lead she she does remind me of katniss
everdeen in a lot of ways
a little less confident and and stubborn
yeah yeah i thought she was awesome and
you know what saw this guy in the
trailer thought he was gonna suck nuts
[ __ ]
four was awesome that [ __ ] rebel
without a cause attitude and then you're
like
he's [ __ ] that kind of character just
often works out being an actor where i'm
like i don't
really you're kind of like balsa wood
like but jai
courtney was a little cheesy i i'm like
i was i saw this and i was like
finally a movie i like this guy like he
was so over the top
his characters wr like my problems with
this movie come out of the writing like
his character's written over the top but
i thought he did fine with that stuff
i kind of was like like finally this
guy's in a good way you're just an
annoying ass
that's all i felt about it yeah it is
the first time i haven't been annoyed
i think jay courtney is one of the worst
actors we have now or it's just the
films he picks where he just keeps doing
a bad job in my opinion
he doesn't have a great uh great eye for
what to do
but this movie i was like oh hey what's
up buff macklemore like i'm glad to see
you
like i thought i would like jai courtney
more than than four but four was i
thought four was awesome i was like i
want to be four
four to four is pretty cool you know
what two chad all these movies are gonna
have some type of romantic element and i
thought the romance was totally
believable actually i bought it this
movie is really well paced in the sense
yeah it is the romance you know it's
coming but it's not like oh here it is
how about that main cheesy focus they
don't like amp up the music or something
you know yeah and you got kate winslet
who's like essentially the donald
sutherland of this world the minute she
shows up you're like evil
i can tell you're evil i don't care how
nice you're being i don't like you so
yeah but she
she's good and i guess i mean she
doesn't really have much to do besides
be a little condescending
but yeah she's fine enough like that's
my thing it's like some of these roles
don't really offer a lot of the actors a
lot to do
no yeah like miles teller's in this and
they're like hey just be a douchebag
again
comes in every 10 minutes beat it is a
dick
here's why you're dumb stiff all right
believe me now stiff yeah like do you
serve any purpose other than being a
dick and
and the answer is yeah one other time
when we need information
and uh the action's cool too like the
fight scenes and stuff it's kind of
brutal watching like girls get beat up
and stuff like that like just
like the sound effects sound real well
yeah and again what what makes the
action all the more
impactful is that they actually do take
time to let you know uh
tris to the fact that she's just shot
somebody like yeah like that impact
takes a toll so then you're like oh [ __ ]
it's not just fun blowing people up
anymore you know and what i really
got from this movie a lot was the music
too though i thought the music was bomb
diggity jump
jump jump like it was intense junkie xl
i think did the music so it's
like a dj jacket produced score by hans
zimmer yeah
and it makes sense why it's good and you
get hon zimmer to help out yeah it's
gonna be good
that's a new thing now it's like
basement jacks did attack the block and
then m83 did oblivion and now you got
this movie with with junkie or whatever
what kind of music for sci-fi worlds is
perfect it's a good modern day but you
know good for the youth
as well it's uh the young people yeah
the youngins out there
and maggie q's barely in this but she
plays cool she's cool
and she's hot to look at she's hot to
look at the only other person that's not
white or black
in the city is maggie q zoe kravitz did
bug me which one was she she was like
the friend who's the one she meets who's
like
black they're trying to kill us here
right i don't get why for the um
gorgonites wait what are they called the
[ __ ] uh desolates
you
um jump off the train though why don't
they just stop it for a brief moment
yeah i don't
that was that was one of those moments
where i was like this seems entirely
unnecessary you guys are just showing
off
like how do you fit in with this society
in any way shape or form
like every time you go everywhere it's
like parkour time and i'm like the first
30 minutes i was like why are they so
you are literally just showing up the
train isn't going there
stop right here they're essentially our
police yet they're like the most
obnoxious people to guard us
their whole way of life or at least
their transportation system seems
entirely impractical
yeah once you get the cops cars if you
need to find bad guys wouldn't there be
at least a couple of you who just
decided to walk up to the train
like are all of you gonna scale the the
tracks and like
jump over the roof and hop in the other
side well and may think you really root
for the main character and uh if you
find yourself rooting for the main
character good enough movie for me yeah
bro
yeah man [ __ ] that negative 10 on rotten
tomatoes this movie is bomb
diggity i would diggity up this bomb a
lot yeah no i i quite enjoyed it it
ain't perfect but you know it's it's a
lot better than i thought it was gonna
be it's a hell of a lot better
i would consider this a good film but i
don't get why it has such bad reviews
like it's a fine film it's good
it's more than just okay like there's a
lot of great things in it yeah
it can be uneven but there's a lot of
really good moments if it has that
all a young adult feel at all people are
like stupid not gonna recommend this
yeah yeah and i mean like it's not a
problem if there's a little bit in there
the young adult stuff is kind of
shoehorned into this movie it's like the
least natural stuff to me but it all
still works
so jerry i guess it's time for us to
give our reasons to see this yeah
what are the reasons to see this movie
reason to see number one
[ __ ] rotten tomatoes the story
that's what i gotta say to you guys not
[ __ ] around tomatoes i tend to love
everything and you agree with ronnie
i love tomatoes every single day one of
the few occasions where i'm like don't
agree with the ratings on this one
what's number two jb
number two i i guess would have to be
shalane woodley or sheriff woody
sheriff woody is awesome in this
hot good actress that's all you need
from an actress good looking and good at
acting simple
yeah simple simple if you're good at
acting you're not attractive
your acting might make you more
attractive kind of like how i feel about
meryl streep when she got older i liked
the casting of that one girl who was
like really tough and that's pretty much
all we get to see
the one who she fights oh yeah the
really tough bigger set one yeah she had
one of the cheesiest
moments though in the whole [ __ ]
movie sheriff woody returns back and
then everyone's like whoa
yeah good job and then she goes hey
that was cool yeah good job out there
and then she just walks away number
three guy had it tim
[ __ ] the rebel without a cause four
liked him a lot james dean is in this
james dean kind of looks like dave
franco more like dave franco than james
and uh yeah what would you say number
four since the camera's about to do
oh number four well you can put them on
the damn list go for it i
i like jack courtney in this room i just
wanna i'm glad
to have liked jai courtney again because
i saw him in jack reacher i was like oh
yeah and then every other movie has like
oh no
i'll admit even though i thought he was
pretty cheesy i enjoyed watching i
bought him in this world
uh five i have to say uh the action
action's really good in this film pretty
sick sick action what do you think six
is
six probably the music right music
music music man hans zimmer producing
yeah junkie xl yeah if i'm getting that
wrong i'm bummed
yeah you're you're just gonna make an
app i think it is gonna be a youtuber
who's gonna be like you [ __ ] you
got it wrong so those are the reasons to
see
detergent it's gonna be a damn good film
for your experience
and so have a fun time alright guys
thanks for checking out our review for a
divergent
why don't you go ahead you scroll to the
comment box
below and tell us what's your favorite
young adult movie that is not
the hunger games and once you're done
with that come on over here and click
this button so you can see more episodes
of reasons to see wherever the button is
yes it's right here and last but not
least
if you want to get updated every time
one of our reviews or videos is out
subscribe
whoa whoa you got to keep your voice
down man i'm sorry i'm about to get
kicked out
i'm sorry i like this place it's just
about as loud as you can i film like
four shows
i just threw mine out longer no that's
okay it's okay
gosh man my landlord he doesn't watch my
[ __ ]
this guy always gets on my ass about the
most minor things uh
well
sayonara scion hour people
my landlord totally bumped me